i'm a multi-millionaire my name's samuel
leeds
and recently i received a message from a
man in
ireland a man who's got no money at all
and he didn't ask me for my money
instead he asked me for my time
he asked me to go and live in ireland
with him
for a week and help him make some money
and you know what
i said yes
the plane was empty because of the
pandemic i didn't tell anybody i was
going
i just went
absolutely beautiful
excited for the challenge
thank you
all right so we're here in ireland
come on
[Music]
the awkward moment when david realized
that i was actually
for real and i really was going to be
living with him for the
how far away week your house i've been
30 minutes i sometimes ask myself
why on earth am i doing this but
if you were a multi millionaire you'd
probably do crazy social experiments
just like this too
hello hello hello how you guys doing
thank you hello good to meet you
hello how are you doing how are you good
though such a welcome
well i'm very excited to find out what
the property market's like
everyone knows why did you want me to
come to your house
it's obviously i really need to be
financially free um
i'm living here it's not i had dreams
but they're not it's not working out
why is it not working out what's
happening just
you know i don't know everything's going
wrong at the minute so
so what do you want from me this week i
want to live here so
i want you to do the impossible to make
me live here
be financially free but you do live here
already yeah but that's not it's not my
own house i mean
okay so you live with your parents all
right what did you do at the moment for
a living
actually i used to be a plant operator
but at the minute i'm unemployed
set up my own business came through the
affection
and look it's just a bad time of the
year now all right cool well first
things first if you want to become
financially free
i would probably suggest that we start
by looking at the area seeing what's
around going on right move
finding deals that'll be a problem
there's no right move spare room
no spare room oh dude this is going to
be really hard
oh man is the wi-fi not good here
oh my goodness not having wi-fi
really really sucks i managed to get a
little bit of 3g
and i can't get connected again and all
the websites are totally different
there's no right move
there's property power which is
different
and i think we're just gonna have to
just hope for the best and tomorrow
rock up some estate agents and try and
see what we can do
it's gonna be a challenge in ireland i
don't know anybody here i don't know the
market
david's got no money
we're just gonna have to hope for the
best and give it everything we got
day one of the ff challenge is rent
directly so simon said that we can go to
agents
so basically we're gonna go to agents
get a property to rent and we're going
to rent it out again and then i'm going
to
profit off the difference so good
morning
hey good morning so what agents are we
going to go to today
i think we're going to go to all of them
every single agent in what's this area
called again
okay that's right this is
a fabulous area man honestly really nice
yeah that's really nice isn't it in fact
let me bring amanda
actually and i'll tell her that i'm not
in the uk because i don't think she'll
believe it
do you realize i'm not actually in
northern ireland i'm an actual island
no you're not i'm in actual island right
now
because i didn't i didn't fly to ireland
i flew to northern ireland and then
drove to ireland that's so
okay that's good that's good yeah but
hey
great area we're literally in the middle
of nowhere
wow david's mom david's mom is here she
cooked us a wonderful breakfast
in fact she even had um she even got a
gift for a
new kid that's coming thank you so much
i'll pass you over to her this is uh
david's mom
hi there amanda how are you david's mom
by the way is the best person ever
yeah anyway babe we're gonna go out
we're gonna we're gonna go to some
estate agents
and we're gonna see what we can do see
if we can get some rent events in
the middle of ireland i know i know
but there's there's like nothing around
here
so we'll see what we can do
all right i'll see you in a bit here we
go it's a beautiful home
it's a beautiful area and this is very
welcome
that's the least we could do here well
i'm really grateful
so you know what i must respect the
pyruvate what
what i don't understand david why do you
want to move out when your mom is so
amazing
when do you reckon i'll actually get a
sick phone signal because at the moment
give it another 15 minutes i do want to
go into agents but i also don't want to
look like a complete
dum-dum when i walk into the agent not
knowing anything so
talk to me a little bit about the area
what's what it feels like we're in the
middle of
absolute nowhere there's no signal
there's no oh it's beautiful though
look at it this is so
i can see why you want to live here yeah
alex is really nice this is where i was
brought up
and uh it's beautiful that is nice so
you want to have a little
beautiful home here you want to bring
your girlfriend here
and you just want to live a nice quiet
life financially free in ireland that's
it
and it's beautiful i would freaking join
you here
i love it the question is can we
create passive income and can we make
money here
because the the unemployment here oh
oh my goodness there's a university here
is the university open or is it closed i
think it's actually open at the minute
yeah
so why if there's a university here and
it's open
yeah that's a good sign we're going to
the university
to see if there's jobs because anywhere
in the world
if there's a university then there's
jobs
if there's jobs and there's people and
there's professionals and there's
students
then there'll be a market for hmos
and if there's hmos then there's also
going to be single lets and we can just
turn a single
into a hmo i think i think i'm getting
excited
i want to move here are there any chance
of a
quick maybe meeting today about possible
hmos
have you got any properties
it potentially could work how much is
that property per month
universities there hospitals really
close and the city is literally
walking distance okay so what what
sort presumably then the rental area
down here yeah i mean i imagine it's not
going to be bad is it let me have a look
at the area and see what's what so i'm
looking for a
room where are we again what's the name
of this place
is that it county fair no where where do
the space
londonderry you have to fill in on
gumtree londonderry
even though it doesn't exist okay
is it londonderry or is it derral
so the rental market it's saying that
they're renting for like
350 pounds 400 pounds of room the area
seems okay the properties are so cheap
the rent is so high so we've just been
into a letting agent and they've
basically told us
that this whole area this street all
around the university
is really good for renting rooms but
only the students
and only between september and july so
there's a few months of the year
like now where it's really tough the
landlords are really struggling
so what are you thinking you know this
is the best time because the landlords
are tired landlords
some of them are faking because and i
think i can really
pick up a lot of a lot of properties
cheap look how many agents there are
midas estate agents oakland city
portland property montgomery quick
blisters these are all
like within a mile of each other yeah
yeah let's just let's just go to some
more agents
okay no problems all right thanks so
much cheers
bye they're so friendly around here yeah
they are and they're so open to just
doing viewings on the same day so
so what i'm thinking is if we can look
at not just go to letting agents but if
we can also go to some estate agents
find some houses for sale it's an
appointment with an
agent we can pick their brand about the
area if we can find a good investment
property we can sell it
and then we can use the money to put
down on a rent to rent deal yeah so i
just want to just dominate this area
i want to speak to as many agents and
letting agents as possible
so they said they're only going to allow
one person at a time
which means that david's going on his
own pav can't go in with the video
i can't go in so who knows what's
happening in there
right now oh
i think they're looking for hm all
properties hmo properties all right okay
no
i've nothing empty at the moment right
that's okay well they will play it beer
then different people
yeah that's great hey good one thank you
uh it's gonna try and get the boss in a
bit earlier it's fully booked out
after and it says there is probably a
five bedroom hmo
there's somebody in it but he's willing
to maybe give us that property
so that could be the next hour it's on
the street did you tell him how rent to
rent works
and was he all right with that he
doesn't really do it but
they know the concept they're willing to
give us properties there's another one
this is we can have a two can we get
inside these houses yeah we'll
probably get them one side in the next
hour
this is coming together on a monday
morning
okay did you tell him that we were going
to be filming yeah and was alright with
that
he's okay oh man when do you want to
view
now come on it's taping
yes our first viewing of the day
these agents are so open aren't they i
just i'm
feeling the vibe david you're good at
this
you're smooth he's a smooth irish
charmer
you're really good man i think you've
just got a real natural way about you
where is the door there's number six
so we've got viewing on this property
which is for let let this property is
for sale
i'm going to call the property that's on
for sale and see what's going on
i want to know how much these properties
will rent for i want to know how much
they're selling for
i want to know everything hi donnie
brook estate agents um just a quick call
my name is samuel leeds i
am i've seen a property that's for sale
with you guys um
right next to the university it's ah
i don't know i don't know what's the
hold on what's the name of the street uh
i just wondered how much that was that
was selling for
uh that one they're on the market
looking 147.5
okay 147 and a half and what sort of
rent would we get for that because i'm
an investor
and obviously i know it's right next to
the university we do our own independent
research
about how much rent we'd get and what
the crack is with the area derek
londonbury
lettings agent and let's just see what
they say about the area
hi there my name's samuel i'm just
ringing do you do you deal with lettings
we do yeah okay so what i'm doing i'm
just telling them that we're buying a
property in this street
and asking them hello sarah just a quick
call i'm buying a property on i don't
know if you deal with lettings but i'm
an investor and i'll
i'm looking for somebody to potentially
help me on with the letting side of
things
okay yeah sure we do so what is the
student market like because i mean i
know it's like a bad time of year for
students
um i haven't completed on the property
yet i'm due to be completing
in the next month or two like would you
wait and hold off and wait for students
or
i think you'd have to be looking
probably august night for a new student
rental
um okay
yeah so basically i'd get more rent with
students but then i'd have a void period
for a while maybe let me have a think on
that then and
and and come back to you guys when i'm
closer to completion and see what we can
work out
yeah all right thanks so much cheers bye
okay so basically here's what they're
saying they're saying
that the student market's popping but
right now the student market's dead so
if we were to buy a property right now
we'd have to wait until august yeah
we'd get loads of rent in august because
but september till july that's the
student time
so what do you think we should do well
if we do a rent let's say we do a rent
to rent now in this house
if we do a rent to rent now and we offer
the landlord guaranteed rent
if we're speaking to landlords now
they're going to be really motivated
because they've got no rent so if we say
hey we'll give you a guaranteed rent for
five years
yeah what do you suggest well i'm
suggesting that we do a long-term
agreement but we
get a bargain rent right we could even
for the few months where it's empty we
could stick on airbnb
i'm thinking three four months of the
year service accommodation okay
and then move them out because they're
just guests and then nine months of the
year
pop in students get the landlord now
while they're motivated
the landlords are going to be so
motivated now they're going to be like
oh my house is dumped do you have to
wait three months
and we'll be like no you don't we'll
give you a guaranteed rent
this just could be an opportunity here
could be an opportunity here hey how you
doing
thank you so much for showing us around
it's a short notice
so basically because of covid he's gonna
get everything all ready for us
then he's gonna come out and then we're
gonna walk around ourselves one hour in
and we've already got a viewing
thank you so much we'll just be five
minutes and then we'll have a quick chat
so that's okay
thank you so what's the asking price for
this entire house
they actually never negotiated nothing
yet we just got that few and so honestly
i don't know because it is
such a good location in terms of the the
university yes
i'm thinking that room would be it
should be a bedroom right and then this
room is a communal room i think we could
push for another so we could get six
bedrooms
and then oh nice and big question david
is this property
is this property already got a license
and stuff we're gonna find out known at
30 minutes
it's very decent isn't it yeah this
would
i don't think you'd have to do a thing
in this house to rent this to students
already fully furnished that saves a lot
of money
yeah 25 minutes from your house
you can see the university from the room
look at that water that's the water so
that's the opposite this is the back the
universities
at the front yeah there there's a
university just up here
oh yeah you can see the universe and
it's already furnished it's actually
nice isn't it
now here's the great thing about this
property students right now
are non-existent the landlord
is probably struggling to rent this
property out
it's already got fire doors it's already
furnished
so all we say to the landlord is you say
look we'll give you a
monthly guaranteed rent we'll offer them
something really low
in the next three months we'll we'll
tell the landlord for the next three
months we're just going to take the hit
but then we'll make profit but we won't
take the hit because we'll stick it on
airbnb for the next three months
you're optimistic and then outside we
just need to put a key safe outside
yeah where when the guests come they can
let themself in
so you wreck short-term nets yeah the
students and then take advantage i don't
know what the
what the short-term let market is we'll
have to go on airbnb and check
i think it's a good time because a lot
of you won't get them in september
you will not get a hmo do i if we if we
were doing this challenge in august
all the landlords would be like on your
bike on your bike
now we've come in at the right time
because now the landlords are like
motivated
so one room two room room downstairs
three room
four room this one's not was quite as
nice
but it's still all right this is a spare
room
it needs to give me 70 square feet one
two three four
five six seven eight nine ten one
two three four five six seven we're fine
plenty big enough the view out the
window
you've got shops you've got jobs i like
it
what do you think of dairy i love dairy
i love derry
i love the estate agents in dairy
they're so helpful honest
and it's quite a small ceiling but
the smallest person so we need to just
make sure that there's there's um
we need to find out what the html
regulations are yeah we're going to find
that out now we're going to have a talk
because yeah i'm not fully sure yourself
how much would we want to offer the
landlord you know what i'm thinking i'm
thinking
we'd want to offer the landlord about
if we can rent this place out while the
students are in town
for say 75. i guess that eighty but yeah
all right we'll call it 75.75 times
four point three three that's going to
be about three to four a month yeah
times five we're gonna get five rooms
one thousand six hundred
minus bills that'll be about 350
mess with one two four oh five hundred
pound profit
we'll want to be paying the landlord
about seven seven five there's two
bathrooms
what are you thinking unless the rental
income we'll see what the rent will be
it's right next to the uni though i
don't think we could pay
more than about 850 though for this no
i'm not going to pay that i think we
have to pay more like 775
800 kind of tops no i'm not paying that
you want to pay even less yeah come on
let's see if working the ghost yet
[Applause]
great where's the agent gone uh he's
just down there in the car
so all right so what what we're going to
say then so we need to find out number
one can we get five people in there
legally
yeah and so much can we rent it out on
short stay let's
we then need to find out later we have a
short story that's or even a thing here
and if it would work
if we get contractors and stuff in there
and relocate us and number three is
how much can we negotiate this for so
i'll let you do that better
and the question is the question is
what's the lowest he could accept and
still live with
yeah also what does the agent gonna get
out of this because they're not going to
be managing it you are
they're going to presumably he'll he'll
he'll pay they'll get a fee off the
landlord right there for finding us
a finder's fee i'm not commit to nothing
but i'll say i'll come back
yeah okay but ask what's the lowest the
landlord could accept if we could offer
a guaranteed rent for four years
no voids no light payments you want to
get as low as we can
and obviously we need to break close as
well if you know if we were to take it
on like a four year
rent like what uh no at least you'd be
able to take but everybody's still level
like on a carpet class hi
so pierce would be the person to [ __ ]
that up dragon
why uh just just a speech
i think you were trying too hard and you
were thinking about your words and you
were thinking
and you think because i told you to say
what's the lowest except to still live
with you like
what's the lowest degree like you just
need to just be nice friendly build up
every poor
also you know that's how i was saying
thank you so much for showing us around
like like building him up building a bit
of a relationship whereas you were just
like
how much would he be able to accept yeah
what's the lowest you know so
i think you seem to be more friendly
you're a friendly guy yeah you're more
friendly than i am
but you just need to be a bit more
friendly but hey hopefully
look at like that's a lesson luckily
though he isn't the decision maker
so if you did f it up you left up with
him we're going to meet the owner later
so before we meet the owner we'll have a
conversation beforehand about like
exactly how to be how to act how to
speak
him again thank him again thank you now
thank you thank you so much
can i just say thank you for showing us
around the property now appreciate it
because of a short notice and you know
appreciate that
no thank you very much and i'll speak to
you soon
thank you exactly that that that goes a
long way
he smiled then he likes you now please
and thank you
you know you know this yeah you know
this right let's go to some more agents
okay
look at this dude hotels within quarter
of a mile
like this one that's running for 165
pounds a night
that's literally samuel just behind this
house
69 pounds i wonder how busy they are
right now
because if we can rent this out even
i mean we've got we've got five rooms in
here
yeah we should be able to make money on
that
it's serviced accommodation sticker key
safe outside
do you think yeah that the hotels are
shut no off
culver they're not they're open for key
workers
we'd need to stick to the same rules as
the hotels yeah but the hotels
aren't shut they're shut for leisure
yeah but they're not [ __ ] let's go if i
go on airbnb i'll be able to find out
how full
the hotels are right now and find out
how full the rooms are
so londonderry i'm getting i'm getting
used to this whole london dairy thing
now
so look these are houses in dairy yeah
entire house
private room would it work but well
let's see we can literally see
five guests we can see the diary
dude it's all full this is great what
it's it's it's full until april
honestly i never knew that it's full
until april
so we rent that house we do it to
students
from july until next year september but
then the months
the house is just the same that's
brilliant look at it
what 40 pound a night for 30 days
is one to 1 200. you're not going to
make a lot of money but you're going to
at least
make a little bit of it and then when
the students come in
in august you're going to make a lot of
money if we get that if we get that
property for 750
i'm confident you'll be able to make
about four or 500 quid a month profit
on average over the year a month you'll
you'll probably make
about 450 times 12 you'll probably make
about five
five five enough grand a year okay i
reckon
which is i mean if we can get two or
three of them
yeah and you know what if we can maybe
try and negotiate more deposits
yeah we could negotiate the rent even
cheaper let's go find another agent
let's go yeah okay
brilliant oh thanks so much i'll see you
back 12 30. perfect cheers
bye now so got an appointment to see
pierce who's the owner at 12 30. okay
and then we'll try and negotiate and see
what we can do in the meantime
um why don't we go on gumtree and see if
we can find some like direct to
director owners we'll do that yeah yeah
because i reckon gumtrey
okay the thing is if we can get in with
some owners direct
we could maybe negotiate we could even
negotiate at least option agreement
do you think that's possible oh yeah
yeah oh well
what's the is there negative equity in
this area you know we can't i i can't
check it off because right move you can
actually check out a spot and so forth
so it's gonna be really hard
so what like what do you suggest what
i'm thinking is
the problem is if we're trying to rent
to rent in this area with a landlord
direct
unless it's already a hmo getting a
license and stuff is going to be a
nightmare
you want to live get your own place why
don't we try and find a no money down
lease option agreement
for you to actually move into somewhere
okay
so how would you lock that up if you if
you can't so londonderry
i'm looking for properties in london
dairy
properties for sale properties for rent
doesn't matter but look there's loads so
this one's over 1200
okay um this one's a three bed house and
for 500 we could just go
look rather than renting it off here for
500 how about this
we'll give you 300 pound a month every
month but then we'll buy it off you as
well
claire we'll buy off you claire in five
years time
four and we can give them the asking
price i reckon properties will go up in
this area
and then you'll be getting 300 pound a
month which is peanuts you can live
there yourself
and then you're gaining from the capital
appreciation yeah so let me call claire
oh we can't call her because she's got
no number let's email claire
let's just hit let's just absolutely oh
we need to i need to register but let's
just
log in let's just hit gumtrey all the
houses that are for sale and for rent
let's call and email the owners
and see if we can get an appointment
today okay and just see what we can see
what we can do
so if we can imagine if by the end of
the day we've got a rental rate and a
lease option agreement on day one
on day one people are so open to
business here you know what uh
as i said your strategies can work here
i think they can
you know as well i feel like in england
everyone's pitching the agents all day
long about rent to rent loose options
here they seem really they've not heard
of it it's like an untapped market yeah
it's an untapped market all right if you
do it at the same time as me
i'll find properties for rent you find
properties for sale
i'll hit all the properties for rent on
gumtree you hit all the properties for
sale and come gumtree
okay and we'll see if you can get the
most viewings today perfect sounds good
alright let's do it i've got one here
samuel for sale and rent
oh nice her name is
una i reckon i reckon sure
if he's on for sale and for rent that's
a like
a sign that she'll accept a lease option
agreement we should pay for this option
oh yeah yeah call the caller caller okay
i'd even picture on the picture on the
phone at least option agreement on the
phone and see if we can get in there
today
okay would there be any chance we might
be able to possibly get in today
hello we need to find somewhere better
signal than this
geez so is this for rental for sale for
for
you know i'm just wondering are you
available today if you know if i call in
no i've changed my mind okay it's about
this state agent
that's what they said agent yeah okay
no problem oh [ __ ]
also i don't know whether you consider
um a tenant buyer
so that we we could rent it with a view
to buying it down the line i don't know
if that's something you'd be open to
go buy yeah
all right all right uh
yeah yeah we have you know i might be
interested in renting the property but
maybe fixing an agreement to buy it at a
later date
right right right where do you live
now yeah well just i'm actually in dairy
i'm
renting a place but i'm actually looking
to get on the market but
i'm just trying to get a few pound
together for a deposit so i'm wondering
you know looks a really nice house and
it just would suit my criteria
and we'll go from now okay i can go
through the property if she's open to
that idea i'll go have a few in and give
her a call tonight
okay thank you bye bye now bye uh
there's two clocks at you
yeah two o'clock which is to be fine
bring your mask
and i'll see you there two o'clock so
we've got a viewing on a property
a nice property where the owner we've
spoken to direct
on facebook how did you find that on
facebook i don't know i just said i just
tried
facebook marketplace and that's direct
defenders i can make the call direct
tonight no money down lease option
agreement live in it yourself
really nice and then and then if if
you've got that and a couple of rent to
rent deals giving you some income
yeah technically you'll set up then
that's me set up yeah as you said
in ireland with you with your misses
hello i'm just wondering how
have you got any hmo properties for rent
in this area these don't
do you know what they would achieve
rental ways per room
hi what were things
okay
that was a bit awkward why did you find
the agent
uh daria simon we're like fully booked
out we're not fully booked out we've got
like
three viewings this afternoon we've got
one though one and an hour
we've got a yeah but we can get one for
the end of the day just find them up and
see what they say
it might be that we can cancel one if
they're really hot okay we could get a
deal just literally on the phone oh
hello i'm just i'm standing here on
argyle street and i see that you've got
a few
a board outside that just may have uh
student-led
for rent that's right yeah i just wanna
have you got any
properties at the minute with a hmo
license
they are affordable down the street okay
on the left-hand side there are a
company called
property services yeah and them and i
they're the main
one but there's my properties that you
see are you even affairable today john
for a talk i am
yeah i'll be up to speak in an hour but
the biggest thing everybody's more
afraid of this [ __ ] virus i don't
know about
yourselves you seem to be jumping about
and it's not bothering you hey
good to meet you good to meet you as
well hi thanks so much and thanks for
showing us around
it's my first time in derry so we're
trying to replicate what we
well what i've done in in um england yes
um david's trying to replicate in dairy
and we need you guys to help us so we'll
see what we can um
we'll try and we'll see what we can do
and see how it goes yes yeah and what
what we were thinking of potentially
doing with that property was running to
students
but potentially putting some short-term
stays in there before
just in case to take
and from the landlord's point of view we
would just be as a do a corporate letter
as a company
offer a guaranteed rent we do that yeah
so that's the beauty of that is because
we know that that rent is coming
regardless because the student rooms go
depending on the quality
325 to 360. that's your sort of here
325's bottom end 360. we need to take
into account some voids because it's not
going to be
completely full do you think you'd be
able to make enough for a profit paying
650 to the landlord
and what's the chance of getting five
students in the risk that you're going
to take
if if things were normal would you get
five you would get five
okay right that's fair enough then um
we'd also as well probably i don't know
if they're going to be okay putting
their brake claws in there
sort of after you know maybe a few
months just on the off chance that it
just totally didn't work
yeah um so we can maybe do like a three
or four year term or what i don't know
what you normally do
and then have a break clause in there
i'd have to just clarify with him how
long
he would want to do a ladder yeah and
i'll come back to you david with that
just
and if we were to get a deal while we
agreed and the landlord was happy you
were happy we were happy
how soon would we be able to get
everything you know get everything all
rolling
as soon as you get the monies in please
and what would we need to pay up front
1300 and that would be one month deposit
one month rent that's correct
okay so we need 1300 pounds 650 deposit
650 rent
but if you could put that to the
landlord then 650 pounds
the pay as you said one month deposit
all month's rent
six month break laws maybe put that
forward to him and then let us know and
if he's happy with that
we could pay tomorrow couldn't we
so basically we would take the property
on
for like three four years but do they
break clause
maybe even six months so after six
months so if everything went really
wrong
yeah we'll speak to you later then put
that to that when do you reckon you'll
be able to hear from the landlord
i'll i'll speak from the date and i'll
get back to you probably
by the end of day awesome i'll speak
later that's okay
see you later bye
six fifty rent to rent on the first
property
they're so open dude we can get that for
6.50
you'll make profit on that that's gonna
do you know what i'm going to do to good
standard i know i can get 85
we worked out that you'd be able to we'd
be able to offer seven seven five
yeah if you if we get up for 650 you'll
make at least 500 pounds a month on that
i mean maybe five or so maybe six seven
doctor
yeah oh dude well done
i can't believe we just got a rental
rent within half a day
what the heck mate this is like an
untapped area
no one's doing rent events here we just
secured a multi-million pound deal
no not quite but it was a good deal
that's what i think you should turn to
ps
it's so smooth that is smooth
did you like it yeah like that so if you
send that to pierce
and then we'll see what he says okay
so it's a one one for everyone the la
the landlord's got a [ __ ] property
yeah mickey nothing pierce is going to
get the property rented
to us because there's no more students
for it
and then we're going to make our profit
so
at this point i already felt like i
could have just gone home
and it would have been a worthwhile trip
change david's financial future forever
but if you want to see more and you want
to see what happened next subscribe
smash the like button because there's
more coming real soon
[Music]
this is me trying to find a deal in
ireland
monday morning i had no money yeah you
see my business ranking but
i never even okay well don't be
disappointed let's just go in
yeah okay there were 1.3 million for
this
and now we are in the uk
i've never seen that
i never even noticed